President Trump is looking again for a
permanent Secretary of Defense acting
secretary Patrick Shanahan abruptly
withdrew his nomination yesterday after
after domestic violence incidents from
several years ago surfaced now the
Pentagon has been without a permanent
leader since December it is one of nine
top administration roles filled by
acting leaders David Martin is at the
Pentagon with more on this story David
good morning to you and let's start with
how has a president responded well good
morning gala the president Trump claims
he only found out about the allegations
this week but to White House sources
tell CBS News they knew about a
Shanahan's troubles when the president
nominated him last month I feel that
there was possibly a deliberate
concealment here lawmakers are
questioning why they were not told of
Shanahan's family turmoil during a
confirmation hearing in 2017 Shanahan
abruptly resigned after his divorce
papers surfaced so his children don't
relive a traumatic chapter in their life
he said it's going to be a rough time
for him because of obviously what
happened but I did not ask him to
withdraw Shanahan and his wife Kimberly
divorced in 2011 a year after she made
this 9-1-1 call to police
my husband conscious that me according
to court documents Shanahan denied that
claiming she punched him in the face
Kimberly was charged with assault which
was later dismissed in another incident
in 2011 their 17 year old son beat his
mother with a baseball bat
court documents reveal Shanahan defended
his son reportedly saying in a memo the
attack happened after Kimberly harassed
him for nearly three hours
Shanahan told The Washington Post Monday
there was never any justification for
attacking someone with a baseball bat
after these revelations even the
president's supporters doubted Shanahan
could have been confirmed I understand
in this environment and the allegations
that are facing him
this is probably a good move by the
administration as the administration
plans to move troops to the Middle East
amid rising tensions with Iran the lack
of a permanent appointment has some on
Capitol Hill concerned we need to have a
secretary of defense without the word
acting after the vetting process is
supposed to prevent what we have just
seen take place
former Defense Secretary Leon Panetta
says national security is at stake any
time you don't have that secretary in
place it raises issues with regards to
the military and the strategies you have
to implement in order to protect our
country the president says he will
likely nominate armies Secretary mark
Esper could be his next Secretary of
Defense but he will be acting secretary
until the FBI completes its background
investigation and the Senate confirms
him Anthony David thanks another period
of temporary leadership for the Defense
Department